leaving for a campaign event in ohio
president donald trump revealed he a
short list for the supreme court vacancy
and he wants a vote before the election
five women are being
looked at and vetted very carefully five
and
we'll make a decision probably saturday
but friday or saturday
it's been confirmed the body of ruth
bader ginsburg will lie in state on
capitol hill on friday the first woman
to be given that honor
but capitol hill is also the place where
the arguments about her replacement
continue
the leader of the republicans in the
senate mitch mcconnell
says there will be a vote what is
telling he said
by the end of the year not november the
third the date of the presidential
election
behind the fact that this senate will
vote on this nomination this year
the american people reelected our
majority in 2016.
they strengthened it further in 2018
because we pledged to work with
president trump on the most critical
issues facing our country
the federal judiciary was right at the
top of the list
today i am nominating chief judge
merrick brian garland
to join the supreme court back in 2016
10 months before the election president
barack obama named merrick garland to
fill a vacancy on the supreme court
it was caused by the death of a
conservative justice
the republicans refused to push for a
vote on his nomination
insisting the election should be held
first
it was something senate democratic
leader chuck schumer insists
the republicans should remember the
senate
has never confirmed a nominee to the
supreme court this close
to a presidential election
if that was how leader mcconnell and
senate republicans
justified their mindless obstruction of
president obama's nominee
surely they must abide by their own
standard
well donald trump wants the vote by
november the third mitch mcconnell
understands the politics at play here he
knows that donald trump won in 2016
largely because of his promise to
reshape the supreme court to put more
conservatives on the bench
and that same issue might just drive
more supporters to his side
come november the third democratic
presidential nominee joe biden has also
been on the campaign trail
but in his speech the supreme court
vacancy never got a mention
he's concentrating on covet unemployment
and health care
issues he believes makes donald trump
more vulnerable
in november's election alan fisher
al-jazeera
at the white house